to send out a tweet with the f-word on
Easter morning promising the murder of
civilians and then saying praise be to
Allah without explaining any of it. You
are mocking me and every other Christian
because we're Christians.
Cinded is a clothing brand that as you
know we're boycotting Israeli products.
Go to cindid.com. Why? I've been wearing
the products for years for six, seven,
eight years from training, gym, boxing,
jogging, praying is sisters and even
women's wear. I urge you guys to check
them out. Got beautiful, beautiful
clothing. Amazing clothes from them in
brothers and sisters. You can see for
yourself with variety of amazing amazing
clothing brothers and sisters that
suitable for all ages and both genders.
Inshallah. Enjoy the video.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends.
The Christian world are waking up to
these Satanist pedophiles. Donald Trump,
Epstein and the rest. Okay, these guys
are the real real pedophiles. They
accuse the Muslim world and the Muslims
and the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him of this evil vile act. Why? Because
every accusation is a confession. Cuz
these people are so perverted, vile
animals that they are, well, it all goes
back to your Zionist that your children
are dying for. They're using your
children to get these people, these
people in power to grape them. And then
they're recording them secretly to use
it against them so they can send your
children uh to die for them. Not only
are they raping your children, they are
sending your children to die like those
12 aircrafts that were taken down by
Iran. Wake up, America. And Tucker
Carson's waking up like Can Owens and
many other. Let's watch the video
inshallah of Tucker Carlson calling out
Donald Trump, the absolute vile pedo
individual. Yes. Okay. Subhan Allah. And
let's watch it for ourselves how he's
calling out. And then we're going to
watch and react to uh Trump's uh tweets
saying that he's going to wipe out an
entire civilization. What is he trying
to say? These vile creatures that are
being absolutely humiliated, yes, these
individuals, these Donald Trump, etc.,
uh are now resorting to a nuclear war to
wipe out the nations. Let's watch for
ourselves. And no president should mock
Islam. That's not your job. No, this is
a mockery not just of Islam. It's a
mockery of Christianity. Who do you
think you are? You're tweeting out the
f-word on Easter morning.
You'll be living in hell. Just watch.
Praise be to Allah. So obviously you're
mocking the religion of Iran.
Okay, if you seek a religious war,
that's a good idea.
But by the way, no decent person mocks
other people's religions. You may have a
problem with the theology. Presumably,
you do if it's not your religion, and
you can explain what that is. But to
mock other people's faith is to mock the
idea of faith itself. And we should
never mock that because at its core is
the acknowledgement that we are not in
charge of the universe. We did not build
it. We won't be here at the end of it.
We can destroy life. We cannot create it
because we are not God. And only if you
think you are do you talk this way.
But it's not just mockery of Islam.
And no president should mock Islam.
That's not your job.
No, this is a mockery not just of Islam.
It's a mockery of Christianity.
to send out a tweet with the f-word on
Easter morning promising the murder of
civilians and then saying praise be to
Allah without explaining any of it. You
are mocking me and every other Christian
because we're Christians. We can't
support that. That is evil. That is an
intentional desecration of beauty and
truth which is the definition of evil.
Well, there you go. Tucker Carlson, a
true Christian, unlike the ve vile David
Wood, No Logic, Apos, the Rat Face. Yes.
and all of these inspiring philosophy
who got someone who's flipping a a a
pedo sending pictures to the young kids
who works with them whatever what all of
them are what the f is wrong with all
these people but Allah subhanaa tala
tells us in the Quran that the people of
the book are not the same you can see
subhan allah him calling him out yes and
not only that it's in our religion
subhan allah it's in our religion that
we are not allowed to mock other
people's faiths we are not allowed to
insult their gods that well we be fa
fake deities gods okay or Even look,
you're not allowed to insult somebody's
mother. The prophetam said, "Somebody
insults someone else's mother." Yes, you
get the sin. Why? Because when you
insult his mother, he's going to insult
your mother back. You are the cause of
him insulting your mother back. So you
get a sin for insulting his mother.
Number one. Number two, you get another
sin for him insulting your mom because
you're the cause of it. And the same
goes to insulting their deities. You
shouldn't do that. Yes, there might be
exceptions etc. when it comes to Abu
Bakr when he said certain stuff. We
don't know if that was abregated before
after. But the point is what? You cannot
do that Islamically. And to see Tucker
Carlson, a person who's a Christian,
calling this vile pedo out is very
refreshing. However, there was a tweet
which I'm going to show you guys where
Donald Trump, as you know, my previous
video that I've done, they've lost uh 12
aircrafts. He said the following. A
whole civilization will die tonight,
never to be brought back again. I don't
want that to happen, but it probably
will. However, now that we have complete
and total regime change, what's he
talking about? The only regime change is
your your colleagues. Yes. From your uh
party who are leaving, there's been a
more of a regime change in America than
Iran. Where different, smarter, and less
radicalized minds prevail. He's talking
about himself. Maybe something
revolutionary wonderful can happen. Who
knows? We will find out tonight. One of
the most important moments in the long
and complex history of the world. 47
years of extortion, corruption, and
death will finally end. God bless. God
bless people of Iran. Is he talking
about Israel? Because everything that
fits Israel. Okay, you can see Allah
subhana wa tala will humiliate you in
this life and hereafter. If you think
that a attack you're going to do, Allah
will destroy your plans and plots. Okay,
never ever think that you're going to
get away with it. Sisters, I hope we ask
Allah to Islam and Candace because they
have good hearts. Their hearts are in
the right place. to our next level of
sisters.
May Allah protect the people of Iran and
America and wherever who innocent people
who are suffering because of this war.